Oh. Hang on.
On. There we go.
She doesn't like penis
and vagina graffiti.
Don't know why
I'm so shocked
that none
of the dresses fit.
Action.
It's...
Hi.
Hello. Welcome to Moordale
for our set tour,
a special pulling back
of the curtain.
I'm gonna to be presenting
and directing
the entire endeavor.
You're supposed to yell
"cut".
Cut. Cut. Cut.
Cut it!
There flies the flag
over the iconic
Moordale building.
The school values.
Urgh,
don't worry about those.
So this used to be
a university gym,
but we have made it our own
little bit of Hollywood.
These are all interior sets
so that's the outside
of Jean's house.
And Otis's house.
-Al?
-Yeah?
-Hello.
-Well, hello.
-Hi. Fancy seeing you here.
Tell me where we are now.
We are in Moordale's
most iconic,
most fa-moos corridor.
Well, it's not
that iconic this year
because all of the graffiti
has gone.
Why's it been painted?
We've got a new monarch,
as you know.
Who, pray tell, is that?
It's Hope Haddon.
Who's she?
Who's she played by?
-Jemima Kirke.
-She's the new head person?
She's the new head person.
And she doesn't like penis
and vagina graffiti.
Let's be a team player.
Done lots of scenes
in this corridor?
Lots.
There's a bit
of post masturbation crumpet
-up in here.
-Like in all night.
I've had
two packets of crumpets...
-Think my clit may drop off.
-Ring any bells?
Two packets? One?
-I do a double here...
-Yes.
-...at some point.
-The iconic...
That is huge.
-Ready?
-And action.
Cut.
Do you think
that the writers
are now writing for you both
because you have
such a lovely relationship
in the real of life?
That's a good question.
Probably. I hope so.
I do think
a lot of our real life...
-Idiosyncrasies.
-...yes...
-They've made it.
-...have blended into the
-Maeve and Aimee tapestry.
-The Maemee.
'Cause you seem to finish
each other's sentences,
which makes me feel warm
and gooey inside.
Think on a good day
it might be really sweet,
and then sometimes,
it doesn't stop.
I think
we're quite annoying.
-You know...
-I know...
I got scared, Mr Groff.
Cand we see your locker?
-Of course you can.
-Is that 122?
If you could choose
any number on the planet,
-what would it be?
-Number one.
-That's my girl.
-Of course.
A Kilo sale advert
which probably
makes a lot of sense,
vintage clothing,
which is very important
to Aimee.
Her notebook is 70s...
Look, a cake sale.
Aimee's made some
vulva cupcakes this year.
Right off you go.
-Bye. Bye.
-I hope to be back--
Hope to welcome you
back soon.
Great!
So, I'm now standing outside
the iconic old part
of Moordale,
which has made up of
very old brick
and it has windows.
Look at that maintenance.
-We're over here!
-Ah, great.
We have Mimi and Sami
who obviously play
Raheem and Ruby.
Two burgeoning iconic
characters of the show.
Mimi, you are considered
queen of the untouchables.
But I'm a lot nicer.
Yes.
A lot nicer in real life.
But it's fun to be a bitch.
Is it really?
-Yeah.
-Might have to try that.
You take that into real life
or not at all?
-Never. No.
-Never.
Sami,
you look like you might.
I do and it's not a secret.
I don't care.
Also very famous
for having your own personal
untouchable bench.
I'll show you.
If you wanted
to join the untouchables
and become a part of
this bench existence,
how would I do that,
for example?
Don't think you can.
is there a scene
you've filmed on this bench
that we might hear?
I've walked away
from the bench.
In a huff.
It's...
-Oh, so…
-That's it.
-All done with a look?
-It's standing up,
-so it's...
-Standing up, then...
-like a...
-Yeah.
-Oh!
-OT!
-Bag.
-It's quite intimidating.
Actually broke up with me
on this bench...
-Oh, right?
-...so it's quite...
So this
represents trauma for you.
Yeah.
He can hold your hand,
but not sure
he can catch you.
If you wanna cry,
you really… It's okay.
I moved on. It's okay.
What's so great about
the position of this bench
in relation to the school?
Is it because
you see everything happening
-or...
-So everyone can see you.
Oh, right.
About people seeing you,
not you seeing
everyone else.
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
Thank you for having me, us,
to witness your, yes, bench.
You're amazing.
Can we just
keep walking away
from those people please?
That's the bike rack.
That's where Eric and Otis
parked their bikes.
Bikes.
Costume.
Let's see who's in here.
Obviously this is
a formal costume fitting.
What you don't know
is that Connor Swindles,
who plays my son, Adam,
is show's costume designer,
Ameritas,
and George Robinson here
who obviously plays Isaac.
Connor, you're giving us
a nice tour of your jacket,
which is very much
Adam's signature look.
Obviously,
playing in
the Costume Department
is quite fun.
Anything else
caught your eye?
Green
is very much your colour.
Did you choose that
because it makes
your eyes pop?
-Yes.
Rosa is obviously
the costume designer.
I remember
when I first started talking
about the show,
I assumed everyone would be
in a school uniform.
That's very much
not the case.
If you have a lot to do with
your own sort of costume
styles, the pair of you?
I liked the jacket with Adam
because it had
that sort of hard shell,
-soft interior.
-For Isaac.
One of them was full on
velour tracksuit.
Why was that vetoed?
It sounds wonderful.
At the day, I think that's
what we all strive for,
is to be taken seriously
as artists.
And I thought
velour tracksuit,
kinda take away from that.
And does it help
being taken seriously
if you have a cock and balls
on your head?
Usually. Yeah.
I remember Robert De Niro,
I had some of the costumes
he used in Raging Bull.
It was called Raging Balls
and then they changed it
to Raging Bull.
Connor, do you have
anything else to show us?
Leave me be,
keep asking George
questions.
You copped quite a lot
of online grief.
How was that living through?
They thought
I was convincing enough
as a sarcastic bell-end.
-Yeah, so...
-So typecast again.
-You're not...
-No.
Don't know
why I'm so shocked
that none
of the dresses fit.
I'm now fully naked.
-Where are we now, Connor?
-The English classroom.
What's Adam like at school?
Is he a good pupil?
-I think he's quite shit...
-Is he?
...as a student
And what was Connor like
at school?
-Quite shit as a student.
-Really?
I was all right at school.
You're a very good artist,
we know.
The cast are very lucky
and the crew are very lucky
to have one
of your magnificent posters.
People think that I'm more
of an expressionists,
but I was actually
trying to make them
photo realistic.
So, you describe your work
as impressionistic,
wannabe photo realistic,
a bit shit.
But that's part
of the charm.
George, what you reckon?
Gonna reach the window?
I reckon,
I'm saying third row.
-First row.
-Good.
Back outside
the modern section
of Moordale,
there is our emblem,
very proud of that,
and the bleachers,
which overlook
our extensive sporting--
-Hey, Al!
-Hello, Patricia.
We're going to Sixth Form
common room,
-you want to come?
-I'd love to, yeah.
Great. Okay.
-This is the common room?
-Yes!
Who spends
most of their time in here?
Me and Kedar.
We're always playing
ping pong, I guess.
-You and Kedar...
-And we're very good.
There is a scene
that Ncuti and Asa shot,
where they were sat
by the window
and I walk past.
-That's right.
-Asa is like...
No...
-Chine, you're head girl.
-I am.
How did that come about?
Hope being head girl,
and I always try and think
what would
Michelle Obama do...
-Really?
-...when I'm acting.
-So, hopefully...
-She's your inspiration.
...she's my inspiration.
Just in terms
of your characters,
how've they sort of morphed
and moved on from season 2?
I guess we're gay now.
Yeah. And I think this year
we've been discovering
what our characters
are really like
in a relationship.
And does it--
Asa get in here!
Hey!
What were you doing?
Walking around on set?
I was bored
and so, I went
to just wonder around.
If you weren't doing this
what would you be doing?
In your trailer?
Would you be doing a scene?
Nothing.
-Many things.
-Many possible things?
-Really? Like what?
What does Asa Butterfield do
when he's not on set?
I might be in my trailer.
Yeah.
I might be throwing
some Frisbee around.
We've a little
Frisbee session going on.
Do any of you
play ping pong?
Yes.
Would anyone
like to have a game?
-Yes, I'll grab the bats.
-You grab the bats.
-So, I just do that?
-Any way you want.
Oh, my God!
Good to know
intellectuals in the school
are very sporty as well.
I'm so sorry.
Where's your favourite
location to film?
Is it at school?
I love Lily's bedroom
because it's so naughty.
And there are just
willies everywhere.
And bums.
Did you have any say
in the design?
No...
But I would love to remodel
my own bedroom
in a similar fashion.
Thanks very much
for bringing me back
to school.
It's nice to be back.
Obviously, I haven't
been here all year,
but I will return and try...
-We're leaving now.
-See ya!
Me and my camera--
I've got to go. Bye.
So, thank you all
for joining me
on this little journey,
this expose
of behind the scenes
at Moordale.
Hope you enjoy the season.
Ah, right.
Let's turn this thing...
There you go. Off.